non so se
un'impressione solo mia ma ultimamente
sembra che tutto debba per forza essere
smart
abbiamo gli smartphone
viviamo gli smart drink qualcuno di voi
assume sicuramente anche delle smart
drugs
e poi tutti vogliamo vivere in una smart
city la città connessa intelligente
pensata attorno alle nostre esigenze e
in grado di risolvere i nostri problemi
ora siccome io appunto sono un ingegnere
meccanico un background scientifico per
cui di bevande smart come nintendo vi
racconto un po cosa facciamo per cercare
di migliorare la mobilità urbana il
traffico che è uno di quegli elementi
che rende ancora poco smart le città in
cui viviamo beh intanto iniziamo con le
belle notizie
le città soprattutto quelle più
innovative quelle più evolute stanno
cambiando stanno facendo moltissimo
stanno lavorando molto su questo fronte
sviluppando soluzione anche molto
diverse non avete appena sentita ma
tutte con un approccio comune che è
quello di offrire un alternativa all'uso
dell'auto privata quindi andiamo dal
tracciati ferroviari
recuperati in bellissimi percorsi
pedonali come il caso della high line di
new york
abbiamo i trasporti iper efficienti di
barcellona abbiamo l'uso massiccio della
bicicletta non necessariamente nelle
solite città del nord europa che siamo
abituati a citare ma anche nella nostra
bologna modena ferrara eccetera questi
sono tutti elementi che quando li
riconosciamo quando li percepiamo in una
città ce la fanno percepire come come
sensata come sarà un'amichevole ecco poi
certe cose ce l'hanno solo ad amsterdam
se voi volete passare una bicicletta con
un portapacchi giallo potete gridare ai
vecchi e quello si fermi di carica è un
progetto comunale per cui se voi volete
aderire andate in comune ritirate
gratuitamente al portapacchi giallo o il
barattolo di vernice per pitturare il
vostro anche portapacchi
ora tornando un attimo
all'auto privata e quindi sa come
viviamo nuovamente le città è qui ce lo
dice la nostra percezione quotidiana
fatta di traffico smog e rumore
situazione di pericolo anche soprattutto
se la città la vivo la attraverso
continuamente con i miei figli senza
peraltro che
l'uso dell'automobile sia riuscito a
rendere è risolvere il problema
principale che è quello di spostarsi in
maniera efficace dal punto a al punto b
al contrario le auto hanno portato più
strade che hanno portato più auto che
hanno portato più strade e un circolo
vizioso che non ha risolto il problema
e poi è successa un'altra cosa
le auto anche visivamente ci hanno
segregato nel senso proprio visivo e
letterale del termine loro stanno al
centro della strada e invece noi siamo
relegati ai margini stiamo sul
marciapiede quando c'è
e guardate che questa cosa del dell'auto
privata
che non è la soluzione ideale per la
mobilità romana delle grandi aree urbane
è una cosa che si conosceva già dagli
anni 50 poi però è intervenuto il
marketing che ha fatto una cosa ancora
più diabolica se vogliamo perché
attraverso la percezione dell'auto come
sinonimo di libertà di possibilità di
esplorare il mondo ci ha fatto
dimenticare come utilizziamo le risorse
naturali
per fare stare in piedi la baracca per
muoverci questa maniera
diciamo che sia cento l'energia che io
mi porto a casa con un litro di benzina
quando la metto dentro un motore a
combustione il 60 per cento se ne va in
calore poi c'è un 16 per cento che viene
perso in atleti resistenza meccanica e
sono ancora in condizioni ideali
a quel punto metto una macchina ideale
nelle strade di roma
magari e perde un altro 12 per cento se
poi ho avuto l'accortezza di utilizzare
un utilitaria e non un sub che non pesa
tanto 11 per serve per portare a spasso
la macchina e un per cento è quello che
è rimasto per spostarmi peso corporeo
è chiaro che questo è il cuore del
problema c'è non possiamo pensare di
creare alcunché di smart
se non siamo in grado di gestire in
maniera almeno decente le risorse
naturali
migliori che questo pianeta ci mette a
disposizione
e guardate che il petrolio è il brunello
di montalcino e alle risorse naturali
cioè non possiamo aprire una bottiglia e
buttarle nel lavandino le altre 99
ora la soluzione a questo problema e
ovviamente complessa e richiederà
appunto una pluralità di soluzioni
sicuramente la tecnologia ci viene in
aiuto una google car elettrica che si
guida da sola e che dopo che ha portato
mia destinazione porta lui a
destinazione e poi va a parcheggiarsi
per i fatti suoi fuori dalle scatole è
sicuramente una tecnologia che ci viene
in aiuto
però tecnologia può voler dire anche
software per falsificare le emissioni di
un motore diesel credo che questa cosa
ci sia abbastanza familiare a tutti per
questo ci sono i regolamenti i
regolamenti come protocollo di kyoto
altri meccanismi che fissano un prezzo
sulle emissioni di co2 sono uno
strumento molto potente per che possono
rivelarsi un incentivo per le aziende in
grado di fare business in grado di
produrre ricchezza col minor impatto
ambientale possibile
e qui c'è un'altra bella notizia
ce ne sono tante di aziende così sempre
di più ce ne sono un sacco l'anno scorso
in europa sono state vendute più
biciclette che auto il mercato del car
sharing è in esplosione e il cosiddetto
turismo eco turismo slow di cui tra
l'altro sentirete avuto alcune
interessanti oggi pomeriggio vale 44
miliardi di euro in europa
e questi numeri certo descrivono un
mercato ma parlano di noi parlano di
scelte che abbiamo fatto ieri stamattina
scelte magari inconsapevoli a cui non
diamo troppa importanza ma che fanno la
differenza
per esempio decido di andare a lavorare
una volta alla settimana in bicicletta
farebbe che alla fine dell'anno ho
pedalato 6 700 chilometri e magari mi fa
anche bene ma ho evitato 100 kg di co2
in emissioni nell'atmosfera
decidono di condividere l'auto fanno 300
kg co2
pedalò cammino usa i mezzi pubblici sto
comunque inquinando meno rispetto allo
standard che è quello di essere in auto
da sola
ecco i siti nel nostro progetto parte
proprio da questo presupposto dare
valore a queste scelte quotidiane più
sostenibili in ambito mobilità come
funziona è un'app per smartphone vi
avevo avvertito
con la quale posso fare carpooling
quindi dare a trovare un passaggio ma
posso anche pedalare andare a piedi
prendere un mezzo pubblico e
vedere incrementato i miei crediti di
co2
ora il risparmio di co2 non ce lo
inventiamo noi non è un'invenzione
nostra ma viene validato da un soggetto
terzo indipendente questo si ottiene
attraverso una certificazione che si
chiama iso 14064 che sottopone il
progetto serie di controlli di procedure
ma che ha come risultato finale
quello di
assegnare un valore economico alla co2
evitata la quale diventa una vera e
propria moneta una moneta però lo neutra
una moneta con il segno più che cresce
si accumula solo nella misura in cui
crescono e si accumulano i miei
spostamenti sostenibili
cosa ci faccio con questa moneta
faccio acquisti direttamente in app
quindi condivido l'auto pedalò un mese
alla fine posso prendermi la bicicletta
pieghevole l'accessorio servizi car
sharing
la birra km zero il voucher per il
viaggio di cosa un prodotto che sia
disponibile sulla piattaforma
ora noi adesso stiamo iniziando a
lavorare con le imprese più in linea con
la nostra filosofia e proponiamo loro di
entrare a far parte della della
piattaforma
aspettando pagamenti in crediti co2 in
questo modo io sono contento perché la
mia
sostenibilità viene premiata viene
riconosciuta ma l'impresa ottiene due
grandi vantaggi
una è la visibilità e la seconda è che
in realtà sta contribuendo a finanziare
la crescita del proprio ecosistema che è
l'ecosistema della sostenibilità che
certo in crescita ma è ancora fragile
rispetto a me col sistema basato sulle
fonti fossili nel quale tuttora viviamo
e guardate questa cosa di
pagare la mobilità sostenibile
non siamo solo noi due settimane fa la
francia ha approvato una norma che
riconosce 25 centesimi di euro al
chilometro a chiunque vada lavorare in
bicicletta è frutto di un semplice
calcolo si sono accorti che la comunità
alla collettività francese spende 15 100
al km per ogni spostamento in auto in
termini di inquinamento sanità uso delle
forze dell'ordine in caso di incidenti
mentre l'utilizzo della bicicletta
presuppone un risparmio per la
collettività
quindi una questione di giustizia
sociale anche non solo di mobilità
c'è una
riflessione molto interessante del
sindaco uscente di bogotà anche una
città che ha fatto
tantissimo negli ultimi anni per diciamo
sviluppare la mobilità a basso impatto
ambientale
che dice un un paese sviluppato
non è quello dove il povero alla
macchina ma quello dove il ricco può
andare invece quei mezzi pubblici
quindi io vi lascio e vi saluto con
un'esortazione con un appello pedalate
che fa bene
ma soprattutto rimettiamo noi stessi al
centro delle città mettiamoci noi non la
tecnologia e vedrete che in questo modo
le città torneranno ad essere bellissime